joining us right now on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line uh is uh
one of the best pass rushers in the game
today uh justin houston his teammate jj
watt and this man are the only active
members of the 100 career sack club in
the national football league along with
von miller as well
um and uh and and and they're the top
seed in the nfc going into monday night
football that i'll be hosting pregame
and half time of on westwood one against
the los angeles rams here on the rich
eisen show is chandler jones how are you
doing chandler i'm doing very well
thanks for having me you got it thanks
for coming on this program what's the
general sense around your team right now
going into this week
yeah of course we are on the snowball
positive ball rolling we got a couple
wins and we're just trying to you know
carry this thing over to you know toward
the end of the season but the spirits
are high you know everyone's just buying
into to the coaches are saying and our
coaching and
and uh we're doing good over here so you
know i mean you guys as you know uh have
won every single road game starting with
the first one this year where you beat
the tennessee titans you had five sacks
and a couple of forced fumbles in that
game uh you've won each one of your your
games uh on the road by ten or more
points what what uh do you attribute
your road success
this year uh you know that's a great
question and and i think as a team
and the staff we're trying to figure
that out now but um you know hopefully
we can carry some of that road success
and figure out what we're doing on the
road and carry that to our home games
because i think both of our losses that
we had were at home so um maybe we can
just take some of that positivity or
that hard road game play and just carry
over to the home game well is it the
camaraderie of just being on the road
being in a plane being a team plane and
just you know being uh being with each
other could that possibly be it
who knows those are those are all great
questions and those are all things that
we're trying to put
put our grasp around now but whatever it
is we need more of it and uh we gotta
find it whatever it is for for these
home games okay what ha what what what
uh what about you chandler and this
defense and um and
and being as good as you have been um
what what uh to what do you attribute
all of that this year
i think that just comes from uh just
experience play honestly um you know
just years of years of seeing things
seeing schemes uh seeing how teams want
to attack this style of defense
and knowing what weaknesses offenses
have and that just comes from experience
so a lot of that is great to my success
what's the toughest offense you faced
this year then
so far this year i want to say the
toughest offense was uh probably
uh the green bay packers and the only
reason why is because they they did a
good job of getting on the football they
got rid of the ball fast they didn't
they didn't let the pass rushers get hot
you know they were chipping and uh so
things like that um those are those are
tough especially for players like me to
be effective i have to you know get have
to get after the quarterback and those
things were a little tough that game are
you a talker on the field do you do
talking chandler do i talk a little bit
here and there it depends how i'm
feeling
um
it's it's never too crazy but i
definitely will say something well i
mean uh in my experience uh anybody who
says a little bit um when i ask that
question uh does a lot to be very honest
well maybe you might have to ask someone
that one of my opposing uh opponents
okay did did you say something to rogers
for instance in a night like that when
you finally i
are you uh are you hinting at my my
discount double check thing that i did
uh
maybe a little bit um
what was that about
i did read something that everyone that
that does that they pay for it so
he definitely made me pay for it he did
did he at least smile because he's he
strikes me he just looked at me he
didn't smile he didn't you know i and i
actually said discount double check i
said it to him he said he didn't smile
he didn't make any gesture he just
looked at me so he challenged me but he
just
didn't say anything
maybe he said that because that that
that's like two or three years old he's
he's got new newer commercials than that
that could have been it i haven't seen
her i haven't played rogers you know i
was out all last season the year before
that so it's been a while chandler he
may not have been offended as a
quarterback he may have been offended as
a pitch man and a spokesman you may have
been offended in that front how about
that he probably looked at me like you
know what chandler that's a little
outdated do something better it is
yeah that's probably what that look was
now that you bring it up oh my gosh uh
what is it like trying to track down
kyler in practice
how often do you get to do that
it gets you ready for uh you know going
against a guy like kyler murray every
day it gets you ready for
the opposing teams the justin fields uh
you know honestly um i didn't know john
fields wasn't playing until i think the
few days before the game right and uh
you know
usually
uh as a pass rusher you have to do extra
drills or do extra things to prepare you
for a quarterback that with that
mobility well we got him right here in
our backyard so um there was really
nothing different that we would have to
do prepare for a quarterback that was
more mobile because kyle murray he i
think he's
he's arms and legs for sure well i mean
you know uh you're you're from if i'm
not mistaken rochester right is that
where you're born you're from there i
was born yeah okay so new york western
new york i guess you would call it what
what did you think of the monday night
game do you consider that football
weather or where you currently play
right now it's kind of like football
weather for you no definitely the monday
night game i'm from new york and and i
started my career in new england right
and that's back when they were shoveling
the yard lines and the numbers
so um
but yeah it was it looked like a pretty
cool game uh they said some of the
players were even wearing scuba outfits
so uh well if that's a thing that's
that's definitely uh scuba outfits huh
this is what they were doing well that's
why i read okay one of the players from
the patriots were wearing
i'll be honest that was a day of the
beach compared to you know uh well you
what you were playing in was compared to
it was a day at the beach compared to
monday night but that was pretty
incredible oh yeah yeah yeah of course
yeah it wasn't the other piece for sure
and i think it was 39 over at soldier
field wasn't it right something like
that right so yeah so you got a good
kyler murray story at least chandler for
me what do you got for me where were you
where you first realized where you first
realized okay i get it now i know why uh
my team went and drafted somebody uh at
the position the year before and went
ahead and got kind of annoying you want
to you want to on the field story i want
to give you a locker room i'll take both
i'll take both
before the locker room story i'll i'll
tell you one um
when kyler was a rookie he always tried
to change the music in the locker room
and he always had an input on what
should be played and what should not be
played
so and kyle's locker is not far from
mine so i told kyler i said once you
have your first rushing touchdown you
could you could change the music so i
forget which game it was but he finally
scored and i and i told him right after
he scored right after he got into the
end zone he came back to the sideline i
said hey kyler now you can change the
music and he kind of smiled at me and he
went back to the bench
i like that
yeah yeah so now he he can change the
music in the locker room now since he
had his first rushing touchdown
so what does he mean on the field i'm on
the field as far as the why we got him i
mean it's pretty self-spoken and i mean
and even now being on the defender i
mean i don't think i've seen anyone
tackle him open field i think he's
undefeated in an open field tackle so
that's pretty fun to watch yeah it has
to be right i mean it has to be from
your position and you're also maybe
even a little bit feel for your your
defensive colleagues in the nfl having
to
deal with that of course
i'm happy i don't have to go after him
for sure well we just found it was his
fourth game of his career when she
scored the rushing touchdown so in week
five how did the music change then oh
that year
he probably was playing more trick he's
a huge drake fan
so yeah so he probably played a lot of
drake for sure so you're in charge you
were so we can pinpoint the last time
you were in charge of the music in the
locker room chandler is that right oh
yeah i'm i'm always playing music i was
playing music today okay i'm not the dj
but i definitely have a taste for music
i have a little speaker i carry around
so everywhere i go the music's playing
what is it then what's on your what's on
your playlist very wide variety country
rap r b
uh anything you name it and i don't have
a favorite artist so my shuffle could be
anything okay gospel
yeah for sure so it's kind of like your
game rushing the passer we have no idea
what you're going to do yep there's an
array of moves right
but eventually you will get home
essentially is what you're saying
all right chandler jones here on the
rich eisen show okay so now um do you
think you're putting together a hall of
fame resume
chandler johnson uh what do you think
yeah i think i i leave that up for
everyone to discuss um honestly and i
know it sounds cliche to say but
honestly i just try to
do my job i'm going out there i'm
playing football uh this is a this is a
fun year we have a special team i mean
that the our roster looks insane i even
look at it when i when i go to work
every day i say you know i never would
have thought we would have these players
this many stars on one team and i know
um this opportunity is very rare so what
my biggest thing is honestly just
capitalizing every single day you know
like as we all know this roster is not
going to be the same next year
so with this with that being said i
think this opportunity that we have
um it's it's huge i mean the coaches
that we have the players that we have
um i mean if you would it looks like a
madden it looks like a a video game
roster honestly jj watt you got a jig
green
kyler murray deandre hopkins i mean
it looks unfair and and we've been
playing like that besides the last two
so hopefully we can keep this thing
going and uh it should be fun
this year it should be very fun so
giving me an answer talking about your
teammates uh in a soliloquy that started
with you know i'm just trying to do my
job did you just go belichick on me did
you just go back to new england roofs
ultimately i want to do my job i want to
put the team first i want to manage the
expectations ignore the noise and uh
yeah yeah so you just you're using all
of those belichick lines right there
that said what do you know what happens
if you you look across the field in so
far stadium next time you're in that
building and you see belichick what
would that mean like for you in the
super bowl for you
oh well we'll see well i don't know
that's that's ways from now we'll have
to cross that bridge when it comes
okay
um and then uh last couple for you here
uh chandler um brockman you want to ask
the question about uh his household in
growing up that you wanted to ask
chandler jones chris brockman my
colleague
go for it sorry so chandler i also went
to syracuse
go orange
you grew up your brother
pro football player super bowl champion
your other brother
maybe the greatest ufc fighter of all
time
how much milk did you guys go through
growing up like boxes of cereal pancakes
what was going on how many pieces of
furniture got broken like what was it
like just rough housing back in the day
yeah we actually growing up we actually
my father actually bought a wrestling
and put it in our basement just so we
wouldn't break furniture when we get
home yeah as soon as we get home we
would take our backpacks off and we'll
go in the basement we'll just get
five-minute rounds a piece and we'll
just wrestle and then about time we're
tired we'll come up and shower and get
ready for dinner but every day it was a
wrestling match and everything was a
competition you know we were running
around the house who who could open the
refrigerator the fastest who could drink
the most milk whatever it was so
we would eat anything and we're not
picky eaters my mom would just make a
big pot of whatever and we'd all eat it
so
it was fun growing up honestly and we
were very family oriented we all shared
this bedroom in a two in the two family
apartments so uh that was fun those
those were the great times for sure you
shared what did you say you shared we
shared the same bedroom all three of us
yeah yeah oh my god i've got three kids
in my you know i'm thinking that's not a
bad idea getting a wrestling mat so so
so your dad your dad's like screw it uh
this is this is potentially dangerous
and and and expensive with with so much
around here he would just put a
wrestling back down and that's it yeah
say go and get it out of the way get it
out of our system before we get to the
furniture now did he did he have a
vision and was that was the matte
octagon shaped was that possible it was
we we all wrestled all three of us
wrestled growing up so it was a high
school wrestling match with the circle
where you shake hands and
wow
wrestlers growing up really so he
legitimately said i'm just gonna if your
guy's gonna wrestle we're gonna get a
mat and we're to make this official like
that happened
yeah we had head gear and the wrestling
shoes and singlets it was a thing who
won it was the thing we'll have to dig
up some pictures and i can maybe get it
on the show for one i mean uh arthur was
always he was he was always bigger than
us
but uh the one thing what was
advantageous for me is that i stopped
wrestling both of my brothers they they
wrestled for their whole careers
actually both state champion wrestlers i
slept wrestled and started playing
basketball and everyone made fun of me
saying you know you're the dribbling guy
and you you
everyone makes fun of all the wrestlers
makes one of the basketball players it
was a winter sport as well but i think
that's what made he made me more
athletic my brothers they they really
can't catch they can't jump they can't
throw um it's just because they're
wrestling that's all i think i credit to
basketball for that how was your game
hoops what was your game oh hoops i'm
pretty good i'm pretty good i won't say
i'm the best on the team deandre hopkins
is the best on the team oh come on now
well we know he's got great hands what's
deandre what's what's dehopps basketball
hoops game like what's he played and he
played college ball you didn't know that
at clemson he was a walking at clemson i
think but he played he was a walk on
that clemson so what's his game does he
have an outside game what has he got
what does he got
he's everything i mean i mean you just
have to see i mean i'm pretty sure
that's footage he's number 44. look how
much andre hopkins well i know he never
steps out of bounds i don't know exactly
i've never seen anything like it i've
never seen anybody with an awareness of
where his feet are in my entire life
he's mastered it it's unreal all right
so last one for you do you guys talk
super bowl openly do you talk about it
no
no but it's not frowned upon i know not
to compare teams but i know on other
teams they kind of frown upon speaking
about that last game um
and but that should be every team's goal
you know i feel like there's 32 teams in
the nfl if your goal is not to win the
super bowl um then why are you playing
and at the same time the same
conversation
um
we don't sit there and say we're going
to win the super bowl or this is our
goal everyone knows that this is our
goal that's what we want to do
um but but we don't we don't sit there
and talk super bowl no okay when you say
other teams
when you say other teams that don't kind
of frown upon or don't talk about it
you're referring to your other team your
former team is that where you're from
i've only been on one of the team
well also well i have teammates that's
been on another team they're like oh no
we don't really talk about super bowl we
don't talk about that there you know
they kind of frowned upon it because you
don't want to think about your looking
ahead and we you know we got the rams
we're going to talk about the super bowl
we play the rams playing tonight yeah
what's that challenge like last one i
lied this is your last one oh what's up
the challenge playing the ram this is a
great t this is a good team and this is
another team that has that looks uh
phenomenal on paper the stars that they
have in their team the numbers that they
put up
um the numbers that some of the
individuals i mean cooper cup i mean the
fastest to 100 catches and even his
receiving yards that guys like that um
like cooper cup he's a guy that can hurt
you and if we don't stop him you know
they just got odell beckham von miller i
mean it's it this is a this is a great
game this is going to be a fun game but
um
i'm excited and this is a perfect game
i'm glad that the stars are lined up
like this on a monday night game because
this is what everyone wants to see and
and i think we know that the rams know
that and uh they'll get our best
football and we'll get there yeah
stafford doesn't do commercials so
you're gonna have to come up with
another line you know
really stanford has do commercials i
don't think so i've never seen one no so
you have to figure something else out
for him but i'm sure you got you got
something in your bag i'm sure we'll
figure it out i got something we'll get
something for him channel this has been
a delight i'd love to do this more often
this has been great thanks thank you
likewise just let me know thank you
that's chandler jones right here on the
rich eisen show of the ten and two
arizona cardinals that was
just all kinds of fun
good old-fashioned fun right there
dad's like screw it let's get a mat if
these guys are gonna wrestle let's get
them singlets let's go
how great is that story i mean
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here